were you nervous hosting Saturday Night
Live when you're seven years old no I
loved it I loved it and Robin Williams
came with Steven Spielberg and they were
there for me yeah why because they felt
like wow there's a seven-year-old girl
on live television maybe she needs uh
Steven was there as you know like a
nurturing father to make me feel like I
was you know I had my support system
around me and he brought Robin to make
you laugh
um I think well they were obviously
hanging out at the time and then Robin
couldn't know the world better of comedy
and television so you know they came in
the dressing room and would just give me
pep talks and what would Robin say
listen kid this is how you do it or or
uh just be calm out there I mean he was
just really nice and supportive and I
was freaking out because Mork was in the
dressing room I was like Wow but isn't
it dangerous when you're a little girl
and all of a sudden uh you're on a movie
said like you were let's take E.T which
is like the biggest movie of all time
but you start to confuse like Steven
Spielberg as your sort of surrogate
father oh yeah I latched right on and
really that's even dangerous because
Steven Spielberg as much as he might
like you personally you were a commodity
you were somebody who made money and you
did a great job in E.T yeah but at the
end of the day I like that now could you
really trust him oh God yes that was the
thing my karma was great taste in people
but isn't it sad when you look back at
it you had to look towards Steven
Spielberg the producer or director of
the movie for a father figure what who
better is it a good thing yeah it is a
great thing and by the way but didn't it
Crush you when he wasn't available to
you when Steven Spielberg becomes your
father figure and he's not really your
father and then you go where's Stephen I
need him he was never unavailable to me
even at your lowest I just saw him the
other day I just booked a dinner to be
with him and his wife on November 19th
and we were still but even when you go
to rehab and you had the problems with
drugs and you were confused I didn't
want to face him I actually was like
just give me a minute I don't want you
to see this and I think that's how
children are supposed feel towards their
parents you're not supposed to be proud
of your bad behavior in front of them
you're supposed to feel shame so I was
glad he made me feel that way and then
we you know I got older he'd I'd walk in
with red lipstick he'd be like can you
just take that down a little bit when I
was like 12 and you know when I was on
the cover of Playboy he sent me the
blanket it was like a famous story in
his production design team covered me up
in the magazine we also well he wrote he
sent you a blanket and he said uh cover
up yeah exactly but he you know but
would you be hurt when he would go on
and make all these other blockbuster
movies and he doesn't put you in them
did you start to confuse that at all oh
God no no you understood the business oh
God yes how old were you when you were
on an ET sex and yet you had an
understanding of the business because
the six-year-old might say why isn't
Steven still in my life why am I not on
the next movie set with Stephen why is
he abandoned absolutely and he didn't I
was on the color purple and Raiders of
the Lost Ark and you know I would get to
get dressed up in costumes and like I'm
actually in some of those movies in the
background I'm not kidding
foreign